[Music]
Wow you know we had this incredibly
beautiful summer day but I'm kind of
happy that summer is over because maybe
now the construction workers will go out
of heat do you know what I mean
it's so nice it's an innocent woman
walking along psychically willing them
please don't say anything disgusting to
me
walking like this and inevitably one of
them might be yeah what do you think
we're gonna do run over and go Tony is
that you you know it wouldn't even
bother me that much if they could show
me one marriage that has come from this
kind of an introduction
you know besides Elizabeth Taylor's and
that didn't work out okay but cuz how
would you ever explain that to your
children you know mommy how did you and
Daddy meet well dear I was walking along
the street one day and your father
screamed the most disgusting things at
me oh yeah something about one eat eat
is lunch off my ass those were the good
times hungry yes of course now I'm at
that age where everyone I know is having
a baby and I'm childless it except for
this boy that I'm dating and he's so
young he has that new car smell you know
they all of these amazing like labor
stories and everything I do in
comparison seems very inconsequential
like you know well you know I was in
labor for 42 days and I didn't use an
epidural I had the baby out in the woods
and they aren't back at work full-time
and breastfeeding and I'm like oh I
bought the cutest skirt when my best ran
out of baby she gained 80 pounds don't
think I wasn't photographed next to her
every day okay
she was in total denial there right
before she had the baby she's like do
you think there's any chance the baby
could weigh up to 80 pounds
I'm your best friend i'm your best
friend i'm gonna go with 45 tops but you
know all i do is go to baby showers
they're the strangest things the world
everyone brings a gift for someone who
doesn't exist yet so I've decided I'm
going to have a husband shower and cuz
then when he finally gets her he'll feel
so much more at home really no no no you
don't have to borrow my toothbrush you
got one of the shower from my mother
yeah well I'm sorry the jeans are too
long we thought you're gonna be taller
sorry about the books who thought you're
gonna be smarter just glad you turned
out to be a boy my sister just had a
baby very exciting and after she had 36
hours of labor she got wheeled out and
she looked up I mean she was like this
adopt but I was singing the alphabet
song to him with my brother-in-law and
he had a different ending to the song
you know cuz that Vanna goes now I know
my ABCs tell me what you think of me how
male okay really because in our family
we're all girls ours was now I know my
ABCs hey do I look fat in these
that's the biggest difference I would
say between my friends and I they're
trying to get pregnant I'm not okay the
worst form of contraceptive has got to
be the pill because you have to keep on
taking it every day regardless of what's
going on in your love life so it's so
nice during those like two-year lulls to
have a daily reminder no one in my life
yum-yum-yum hey it's time for my loser
pill
can you imagine if you had to wear a
condom for 30 days before it was any
good and I think so
day 28 someone might call so I've been
dating this very nice Puerto Rican
doctor the PRD R and he took me salsa
dancing I thought I was doing really
well and never heard this woman saying
oh look at the Deaf girl trying it's
ridiculous though when you end a
relationship you know cuz men always say
the same thing to me I'm gonna try and
work it out with my wife no I'm sorry no
they all say the same thing you know
let's still be friends yeah that's like
being freed from a kidnapper and saying
keep in touch hey remember that torture
call me we'll have coffee you can pour
it on my lap okay I'm done thank you
[Applause]